now to some very emotional testimony in
the murder trial of Alex Murdoch in
South Carolina the disgraced attorney's
surviving son his name is Buster took
the stand as a witness for the defense
yesterday Murdoch has pleaded not guilty
in the shooting deaths of his wife
Maggie and his other son Paul Nikki
Batiste is at the trial Nikki good
morning to you
Gail good morning Buster Murdoch has
been in court every day since the trial
began yesterday he took the stand and
testified for about two hours he
remained composed except when he was
asked about the moment he learned of his
mother and brother's deaths
he asked me if I was sitting down and I
was like yeah and then he you know
sounded odd and then he then he told me
that that my mom and brother had been
shot Buster murdaugh held back tears
Tuesday as he talked about the moment
his father Alec murdaugh called him with
devastating news it was a few hours
after Alex says he found Maggie and
Palmer doll shot to death Buster says he
then rushed to his father's side what
was his demeanor yeah his demeanor was I
mean he was destroyed it was heartbroken
I walked in the door and saw him and
um gave him a hug and just
just broken down the 26 year old
described a tight-knit family that
communicated constantly by phone
about a week before the murders the
family had gathered for a birthday
celebration for Alec whom Buster
described as a devoted dad was there
ever any violence in the family no sir
Buster did say he wasn't aware of the
severity of his father's opioid
addiction he did a few
he did a few kind of like at home just
self detoxed a couple times and you know
thought
you know once he did that that you know
get off of him but that was kind of my
general knowledge about it all
right you thought he he had beat it
that's right yes sir the prosecution has
argued that Alec murdaugh murdered his
wife and son in an attempt to distract
from his alleged Financial crimes that
were about to be uncovered you had no
knowledge of your financial your dad's
financial difficulties at all did you no
sir
the defense also called a forensic
engineer to the stand who suggested the
shooter was someone much shorter than
Alec murdaugh but prosecutors questioned
the expert's credentials the defense
says it plans to rest its case on Friday
which means the jury would likely begin
deliberations next week Nate
Nikki thank you so much